[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 sur tv78
mardi 24 octobre voici les titres de
l'actualité
elles ne font désormais plus qu'une les
polices municipales de plaisir et des
clés sous-bois ont fusionné depuis cet
été une mise en commun des moyens pour
améliorer la sécurité le service auprès
d'un bassin de près de 50000 habitants
entre les deux communes explication et
premier retour d'expérience dans cette
édition témoigner pour mieux comprendre
le handicap psychique il y a quelques
jours la médiathèque du canal à Montini
le Bretonneux proposait ses
bibliothèques vivantes des personnes
malad ont ainsi pu livrer leur histoire
à de parfaits anonymes une manière
d'aller au-delà des idées reçues et de
libérer la parole retour en enfance
garantie au château de Breteuil le
weekend dernier les Playmobil ont pris
possession de l'Orangerie du domaine
situé à choix iselle une exposition pour
bien lancer le programme des activités
des vacances scolaires sur place et puis
elle est connu mondialement la toile de
joui à des adeptes jusqu'en Amérique et
en Asie et les plus grands couturiers
s'en inspirent encore et mais depuis le
19e siècle cette célèbre etof n'est plus
fabriqué à jou en Josas pour localiser
la production dans sa commune d'origine
et perpétuer son héritage un projet de
cité de la toile est en préparation
l'ambition est grande avec 30 millions
d'euros d'investissement on en parle
dans les invités du 78 en deè partie
d'émission et ce sera tout à l'heure
avec Christophe ruot qui est ma adjoint
de jouillan Josas délégué à
l'attractivité et au développement
économique il y aura aussi Charlotte du
Vivier lebrin qui est la directrice du
Musée de la toile de jouille en plateau
autour de moi les journalistes de la
rédaction de tv78 Régine ralche bonsoir
bonsoir alors avec vous dans un instant
vous allez nous présenter l'actualité en
bref à retenir de ce mardi 24 octobre
dans les ivelines en face de vous il y a
Clara de Frutos bonsoironsoir également
donc journaliste de la rédaction tv78 et
avec vous on va parler d'économie de la
talent Academy de la software République
dites-nous tout oui c'est ça hier toute
la matinée les membres de la software
République se sont réunis à l'école 2600
à montinil breteneux ils a présenté les
premières réalisations et l'ambition de
sa talent académie talent academmy
softowire République on va détailler
tous ces termes dans un instant dans le
78 mais d'abord les polices municipales
d'éclais sousbois et de plaisir ont
fusionné la mutualisation de ces brigade
a pour but d'améliorer la sécurité et le
service auprès des habitants des deux
communes un reportage de vous Clara de
Frutos de vous également Régine ralche
et aussi de Louis
Douchin depuis cette été les polices
municipales des clés sous-bois et de
plaisir ne font plus qu'une cette
initiative menée par les conseils
municipaux des deux commune devrait
répondre à l'une des principales
problématiques le manque d'effectifs car
au clé sous vois la police municipale
n'existait plus on avait exactement la
même vision des choses c'est-à-dire une
police efficace mais de proximité et que
les sous-bois n'en avaient pratiquement
plus des policiers donc on s'est dit
pourquoi pas essayer de nous réunir et
de voir comment on pourrait monter en
puissance et surtout devenir attractif
et efficace pour la population parce que
le but premier c'est bien celui-là
renforcer les effectifs c'est donc
l'ambition première de cette fusion ça
va nous permettre d'attirer plus de
policiers municipaux aujourd'hui il y a
21 ou 22 policiers municipaux l'objectif
en mettant des moyens communs nous
espérons arriver à 30 ce qui permet
d'avoir plusieurs brigades au niveau de
la cette police de proximité et pour le
moment cette initiative semble porter
ses fruits deux personnes ont déjà été
recrutées et parmi eux il y a David
désiré directeur de police municipale
intercommunale il assure depuis quelques
mois la coordination de cette fusion
séparément les communes avaient des des
des des moyens qui leur permettaient de
limiter leur action dans l'espace et
dans le temps là le fait que les deux
communes fusionnent leurs moyens vont
permettre de par exemple d'élargir la
plage horaire de peut-être tout un tas
de choses qui vont des perspectives qui
vont être beaucoup plus importantes les
choses évolueront avec avec un un
calendrier qui reste encore à définir
mais les choses c'est clair vont vont
évoluer mais dans le dans le but
principal c'est de pouvoir rendre une
comment dire une mission de service
public aux administrés des deux communes
le local princip de la police
intercommunale se situe à plaisir de son
côté la ville des clés sousbois conserve
un petit bureau annexe les habitants
pourront s'y rendre pour déposer des
déléances ou prendre des
renseignements ce n'est pas la première
fois d'ailleurs que deux polices
municipal fusionne à 50 ans en yeline en
2018 les villes de morpa et de coignère
avaient déjà tenté l'expérience avant
d'y mettre fin on va faire le point à
présent sur le reste des actualités dans
les
ivlines
et c'est avec vous Régine ralège des
propositions pour répondre à l'urgence
des quartiers prioritaires elles ont été
remises cette semaine à Emmanuel Macron
par l'Association des Maires villes et
bonlieux- defance oui et ce rapport
propose 10 mesures d'urgence notamment
sur l'éducation l'emploi la sécurité à
titre d'exemple l'insertion
professionnelle par le sport ou encore
le retour des contrats aidés associatifs
et public l'objectif c'est d'apporter
des solutions aux problèmes récurrents
que rencontrent les quartiers populaires
et parmi les membres de l'association
ayant remis ce rapport au chef de l'État
se trouvait Catherine Arnou maire de la
ville de Chantelou lévges et
vice-présidente de l'association un
comité interministériel des villes
devrait d'ailleurs se tenir à Chantelou
lévg ce vendredi 27 octobre pour donner
suite à ses propositions c'est une
première en une semaine et j'ai envie de
dire heureusement pas d'évacuation ce
mardi pour le château de Versailles et
des évacuations d'ailleurs qui ne sont
pas sans conséquen entre 100 et 150000 €
c'est le préjudice estimé pour chaque
évacuation du château de Versailles
selon l'avocat du site iinois depuis le
14 octobre le domaine a dû être évacué à
Sep reprises en raison de fausses
alertes à la bombe ces montants
correspondent notamment au billets
remboursés et à la baisse de
fréquentation de certains visiteurs un
mot de sport et du basket un camp de
basket à destination des jeunes est
organisé depuis ce lundi et ce jusqu'à
ce samedi au Hoops corner de carrière
soupoissie il a été imaginé par michaell
Mokongo ancien basketteur professionnel
qui a joué en fin de carrière à l'ESC
trap Saint-Quentin en Yveline au
programme des exercices le matin et
l'après-midi avec différents coachs et
préparateurs on écoute Michel Mokongo au
micro de tv78 le concept de ce camp
c'est d'essayer de voilà de développer
la région parce que nous avons beaucoup
de clubs de basketball et une population
qui est assez jeune l'idée c'est c'est
voilà d'essayer de d'aider les jeunes
qui ont vraiment besoin de se développer
techniquement sur le basketball et aussi
de de de de répertorier un petit peu
leur faiblesse et d'avoir un
accompagnement ce que j'appelle XXL
autour de voilà tout ce qui est
préparateur physique tout ce qui est
coach mental tout ce qui est docteur
tout ce qui est physiothérapeuse tout ce
qui est nutritionniste tout ce qui
est vraiment autour du basketball autour
de la communauté sportive et si vous
voulez vous aussi vous inscrire il reste
encore des places vous pouvez contacter
l'organisateur via le site internet qui
s'affiche à l'écran et d'ailleurs en
parlant d'événement la murderur Pary le
jeu de rôle grandeur nature du
département des ivelines et est annulé
en raison de l'alerte urgence attentat
il devait se tenir à l'ancien domaine du
de Madame Élisabeth le 28 octobre
prochain les équipes de l'événement vous
invitent à suivre leur programmation sur
le site mysteries Hunt pour connaître le
cadre le la nouvelle date de report
merci rgine pour toutes ces actualités
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi près
de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
information dans les ivelines qui vous
fait réagir et n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news
au chapitre économique on revient sur
cette table ronde qui s'est tenu hier à
l'école 2600 à Montini le Bretonneux
Clara de Frutos vous étiez sur place on
parlait tout à l'heure de cette software
République qui présentait son écosystème
collaboratif de formation son nom la
talent Academy toute la matinée les
membres de cette software République ont
détaillé les premières réalisations et
ambitions de cette talent Academy alors
il y a peut-être des termes qui
échappent à la connaissance de nos
téléspectateurs tout d'abord qu'est-ce
que la software République et ben en
fait c'est une initiative qui a été
lancée en avril 2021 par six grands
groupes d'ASO système eviden atthos
orange Renault group St
microélectronique et Talès le but c'est
faire face au manque d'ingénieur en
France mais surtout au manque de jeunes
sortant de formation scientifique il
manquerait près de 20000 nouveaux
ingénieurs diplômés en France selon le
selon le syndicat sino ingénierie et
donc c'est là qu'intervient la talent
academmie tout compris l'objectif est
simple susciter des vocations et attirer
les jeunes en particulier les jeunes
femmes vers le monde de la technologie
et de l'industrie alors pour se faire la
talent Academy elle articule son
programme autour de trois grands axes
l'éducation le recrutement et la
formation ils correspondent aux trois
moments clés d'une carrière
professionnelle pour ce qui est de
l'éducation le programme c'est le
programme talent Factory qui s'en charge
il est destiné aux jeunes entre 15 et 20
ans donc dès le collège des
représentants d'entreprise vont par
exemple à la rencontre de ces jeunes
pour susciter des des passions il y a
ensuite la Talente incubator ce
programme d'apprentissage est dédié
cette fois-ci au 20 25 ans qui sont à la
recherche de leur premier emploi et puis
il y a la talent accélérator qui
intervient en cours de la carrière alors
Sophie Duma directrice de la talent
Academie Académie et de la software
République chez Renaud nous en dit plus
alors oui ça ça ça ça fonctionne sur le
programme incubateur par exemple nous
avons aujourd'hui une communauté avec à
peu près 700 apprentis donc à qui nous
proposons des des activités diverses par
exemple des des visites de sites des des
rencontres avec des start-up parce que
ces jeunes ils sont friants de ce monde
de des start-up donc on les invite à
rencontrer des des fondateur de start-up
qui travaillent dans dans software
République par rapport au au programme
de de formation continue là nous avons
lancé cette année un programme de Master
en cybersécurité avec Orange et l'École
polytechnique et donc là Renault par
exemple a envoyé des collaborateurs dans
dans ce
master Sophie dum a répondu mais est-ce
que pour le moment ça fonctionne alors
oui selon les personnes qui portent ce
programme donc on écoute une nouvelle
fois Sophie Duma qui cette fois va nous
expliquer à quoi correspond la talent
accéérator nous avons le programme
accélérateur qui là est un programme de
formation continue dédié à l'ensemble
des collaborateurs des six entreprises
de la softwire Rpublique et là nous
avons comme objectif de former 40000
collaborateurs à horizon 2025 et donc la
talent academmie de Software épubl est
un pilier complémentaire aux politiques
de ressources humaines qui existent dans
nos entreprises et qui va permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif
ambitieux alors cette initiative elle
est inédite en France et en Europe et
comme vous avz pu le voir la Talente
académie semble encore avoir beaucoup de
choses à offrir merci Clara pour cet
éclairage sur le sujet vous reviendrez
d'ailleurs sur la talent Academy dans le
premier numéro de la saison du skycho
qui est àaraître cette semaine sur
tv78 des espaces d'expression pour mieux
comprendre le handicap psychique
l'objectif des bibliothèques vivantes
organisé il y a quelques jours par la
Médiathèque du canal à Montini le
Bretonneux le principe une personne
malade livre une partie de son histoire
durant une dizaine de minutes à un
anonyme une manière d'All aller au-delà
des idées reçues pour libérer la parole
Julien Leroi bonjour Sophie merci d'être
venu me lire se dévoiler pour faire
tomber les préjugés ce mercredi 18
octobre se tenait la première édition
des bibliothèques vivantes à la
médiathèque du canal de Montini le
Bretonneux une rencontre entre des
personnes atteintes de handicap
psychique et le grand public autour de
la métaphore du livre le malade raconte
un chapitre de son histoire suivi d'un
temps d'échange un concept pour ouvrir
la différence questionner pour avoir
moins peur ouais le rétablissement des
personnes c'est pas juste son affaire à
lui je pense que c'est l'affaire du
collectif c'est l'affaire de tous de
chaque citoyen si on est dans une
démarche
d'inclusion il faut qu'on puisse
accueillir quelqu'un qui souffre d'un
trouble quel qu'il soit du coup c'était
ma dernière hospitalisation ça remonte à
plus de 7 ans depuis l'adolescence edvig
souffre de troubles bipolair alternance
entre dépression et phase euphorique une
pathologie révélée à l'âge de 28 ans
après de nombreuses années d'érance
diagnostique cette espace d'expression
lui permet de libérer la parole les
personnes étaient très ému face à ce que
je pouvais leur raconter
et donc voilà ça m'a ça m'a touché aussi
elles sont beaucoup dans l'écoute et
beaucoup dans l'échange et vraiment
enfin c'est agréable quoi ça permet de
nous confronter à d'autres choses à
élargir notre notre façon voir le monde
et et de voir les autres aussi quoi ce
jour-là 11 usagers du centre
médico-psychologique à saint-cir ou de
l'hôpital de jour Eugène Bleuler à
Versailles ont livré leurs histoires de
prochaines éditions pourrai être
organisées dans des universités ou des
festivals l'espoir de pouvoir enfin lire
en l'autre comme dans un livre
ouvert on ouvre une page culture dans le
[Musique]
78 comme tous les mardis une salle du
territoire vous donne trois raisons
d'aller voir sa prochaine programmation
ce soir le théâtre coluge de plaisir
nous parle des crabes un spectacle pour
le centenaire de la naissance de Roland
Dubillard pour vous convaincre Florence
Camoin au micro de Mathilde Francou
bonjour je suis Florence camoi
directrice du Théâtre Coluche
aujourd'hui je vais vous donner trois
raisons d'aller voir le spectacle les
[Musique]
crabes
premièrement c'est une création pour le
centenaire du billard un énorme succès
au festival of d'Avignon deuxièmement
c'est une comédie totalement absurde où
vous allez énormément rire et
troisièmement une distribution
fantastique avec Denis Lavant et Maria
Machado en tête voilà c'était mes trois
raisons pour aller voir les crabes de
Roland du billard le 24 novembre c'est
un vendredi à 20h30 au Théâtre Coluche à
[Musique]
plaisir c'est devenu un rendez-vous
habituel pour le château de Breteuil les
Playmobil ont de nouveau investi
l'Orangerie du domaine situé à Choisel
le temps d'un weekend une exposition
pour vivre de grandes histoires avec de
petits personnages Mélanie poquet et
Gabriel Gontier partout à tis les
Gaulois ont débarqué au château de
broteuil les Gaulois mais aussi les
hommes préhistoriques les dinosaures et
même l'espace
mais tout petit les Playmobil se sont
installés le temps d'un weekend au
château de Breteuil pour le plus grand
plaisir des visiteurs il y en a pour
tous les âges on a beau même être très
très très adulte on retourne mon enfance
c'est c'est vraiment c'est magnifique il
y a beaucoup de détails c'est vraiment
super beau il y a plein de choses à voir
on sait même plus où regarder tellement
il y a de choses à à voir il y a plein
de petits détails que ça part des
végétaux animaux que ce soit aussi les
costumes des détails rigolos des détails
historiques le thème de cette année au
fil de l'histoire c'est la 6e fois que
le château éelinois fait appel à
Dominique betune pour réaliser une
exposition autour de la célèbre marque
de jouet allemande il y a beaucoup de
choses ici qui sont modifiées c'est des
Playmobil qui n'existent pas qui ne sont
pas vendu par la marque donc ce sont des
des objets de collection qu'on a réalisé
en impression 3D surtout donc ça a pris
beaucoup beaucoup de temps donc il y a
des choses effectivement qui sont
dessinées à l'ordinateur auparavant le
château de bretoil a lancé les vacances
de la tousin des animations vont courir
pendant 2 semaines avec toujours de
nouvelles
histoires avant les invités du 78 coup
d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain et des conditions similaires à
aujourd'hui pour votre journée de
mercredi dans les ivelines le matin
quelques gouttes sont attendues dans le
secteur de Versailles il fera en moyenne
de 11 à 13°grés sur le territoire
l'après-midi des éclaircis pour toutes
les ivelines les températures seront en
légère baisse par rapport à aujourd'hui
compté 15 15 degr à Mantel jolie 13
degrés à Rambouillet 14°grés à Oudan et
Versailles et demain mercredi 25 octobre
nous fêterons les darias tout de suite
les invités du C suite
[Musique]
elle a des adeptes dans le monde entier
des États-Unis au Japon les grands
couturiers s'en inspirent encore et
dernier exemple en date le dernier
maillot extérieur de l'équipe de France
de football a fait un petit clin d'œil à
cette étof célèbre la toelle de joui est
au cœur d'un projet d'envergure qui se
lance à joui en Josas la cité de la
toile c'est le nom de ce projet est
porté par la Ville en partenariat avec
le musée de la toile de joui
l'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc et
le département des ivelines parmi les
ambitions notamment fabriqué de nouveau
à joui en Josas cette célèbre étof on ne
produit plus de toile de jouis sur place
depuis le 19e siècle alors pour en
parler mes invités m'ont rejoint en
plateau christophhe Ruau bonsoir ma
adjoint de Jouan Josas délégué à
l'attractivité et au développement
économique il est également Charlotte du
Vivier lebrin bonsoir et vous êtes vous
la directrice du Musée de la toile de
jouille alors pour commencer j'ai envie
de faire un petit point définition
pourquoi on parle de cité de la toile
dans ce projet alors pour le mot cité
c'est très simple pour revenir à
l'étymologie du mot notamment grec
puisque littéralement on parle de
fédérer faire parler ensemble les
citoyens et l'idée elle est là sur ce
projet là en fait l'ambition c'est de
d'utiliser la toile de jouis pour
finalement rassembler
fédérer des artisans des créateurs des
designers des chercheurs dans un lieu
unique qui serait donc qui sera la cité
de la toile euh avec notamment pour
créer un
écosystème économique culturel euh à jou
en Josas et donc à Jouan Josas cette
étof est né au 18e siècle l'œuvre bien
sûr d' berkampf les les ateliers
d'impression était parmi les leaders en
Europe on peut même dire que c'était le
premier atelier d'impression textile en
Europe on parlait des déjà à l'époque
Charles duvier lebrin de cité de la
toile pour Jan Josas non on parlait de
manufacture on a d'abord parlé d'atelier
parce que c'est un artisan qui est
devenu un industriel et on a commencé
avec un petit atelier qui existe
toujours le bâtiment existe toujours et
ça s'est transformé effectivement en un
énorme une énorme manufacture et ça a
été une importante aventure industrielle
en fait al on va parler des objectifs
dans un instant mais les enjeux tout
d'abord on le disait il n'y a plus de
touelle de jouit qui donc qui est
produite jou Josas depuis le 19e siècle
c'est c'est de répondre par exemple à
l'un de ces enjeux quels sont les enjeux
autour de ce ce projet oui tout à fait
aujourd'hui en fait on a on a un enjeu
c'est que vous parliez du du maillot de
l'équipe de France tout à l'heure donc
on voit que la la toile de jouille
inspire au niveau mondial aussi euh
Japon États-Unis mais ça n'est plus
rattaché au territoire c'est-à-dire que
le grand public ne va pas rattacher par
exemple la station de métro obercf qui
est euh qui a fondé la toile de joui euh
le grand public ne rattache plus au
territoire de joui et donc l'enjeu il
est là c'est vraiment qu'on puisse faire
renaître la toile de joui à jou en Josas
avec ce projet de cité de la toile il y
a aussi j'imagine un enjeu autour de
l'activité textile en France 97 %
d'importation pour l'activité textile
qui ne représente que 11 % des des
entreprises en France il y a aussi a il
y a une carte à jouer j'ai envie de dire
il y a une importante carte à jouer le
covid l'a montré on a besoin de se
libérer de la dépendance des
importations on a aussi besoin et ça
c'est d'un des enjeux du du projet de
réimplanter des savoir-faire
l'impression de la toile de joui au 18e
c'était une impression qu'on pratiquait
comme en Inde au bloc de bois à la
planche de bois et c'est une pratique
qu'on ne qu'on ne sait plus tellement
mettre en œuvre en France et donc le les
enjeux ce sera vraiment de d'avoir des
circuits de fabrication plus courts plus
vertueux pour la nature pour
l'environnement et aussi pour le
consommateur et puis aussi de de de de
de réapprendre à pratiquer ce
savoir-faire et le transmettre avec de
la formation alors le projet a été
présenté au grand public il y a quelques
jours plusieurs objectifs on va
peut-être pas tous les détailler mais
les les principaux objectifs de ce
projet cité de la toile quels sont-ils
alors les principaux objectifs on a tout
d'abord le on va on peut parler de pôle
puisqu'il y a le l'idée c'est quand même
d'installer un pôle notamment de
formation et de
recherche l'idée c'est également de
relancer une manufacture nouvelle donc
de rel la fabrication à toile de jou de
la toile de jou à jou en Josas
euh la recherche la recherche aussi
puisque comme l'a dit Charlotte c'est
vrai qu'un des enjeux fondamentals
aujourd'hui l'industrie textile est
l'une des la deuxième plus polluante au
monde on a vraiment besoin de relancer
de la recherche en France et donc
Christophe ru a commencé à parler des
des quatre pôles autour desqueles va
s'articuler justement ce ce projet cité
de la toile dans l'épaule il y a
patrimoine et création l'idée c'est de
donner un une autre dimension au musée
de la de la la toile de jouille
exactement en fait on on réfléchit et on
vous en parlera plus tard un un bâtiment
qui va accueillir cette cité de la toile
qui va accueillir donc les trois
premiers pôles production formation et
recherche et aussi un pôle patrimoine un
musée mais qui serait pensé autrement
avec des outils de médiation plus
innovants plus numériques avec un accès
aux collections qui soit aussi plus
interactif sous forme parfois de
matériotthèque et
de proposer aussi des expositions
beaucoup plus ambitieuses sur le textile
au sens large qui puisse accueillir du
grand public mais aussi des
professionnels et que ce soit en fait
une cité comme l'a expliqué Christophe
ruot au départ un endroit qui fédère des
intérêts des
activités autour de la filière dans la
filière textile pour la filière textile
et et de créer des interactions on
imagine bien parce que il y aussi le
pôle développement et services qui est
qui va être pensé comme un tierlieu donc
c'est aussi de favoriser les rencontres
au sein de cette cité de la toile
exactement tout à fait avec des fablabes
avec profiter de nos outils de
production pour les mettre à disposition
de designers de professionnels qui
voudrai expérimenter des techniques des
motifs et effectivement encourager ce
lieu de rencontre et d'échange à tous
les niveaux en fait de la cité volonté
aussi allez-y avec aussi un sacré levier
de développement économique c'estàdire
que ça va être un très beau cas école
pour montrer comment la culture peut
être un levier de développement
économique on a parlé de de de fédérer
des artisans créateurs dans des villages
on a parlé de Fabla pour pouvoir
produire aussi des quantités mais il y a
pas besoin d'imiter l'idée c'est
vraiment de recréer de s'appuyer sur
notre notre notre culture la toile de
jouill on l' dit relancer aussi une
activité d'impression sur place ça peut
être profitable pour la ville pour tout
le territoire aussi qui qui l'entoure
alors oui ça sera déjà profitable pour
la cité de la toile puisquen fait vous
l'avez dit en introduction c'est un
projet avec 30 30 millions
d'investissement donc c'est un très
lourd
investissement évidemment on a le
soutien des soutiens public Versailles
Grand Parc le département qui sont
déterminants pour pouvoir lancer ce
projet à l'échelle d'une commune de 8000
habitants euh mais l'idée c'est de
pouvoir effectivement miser sur la
manufacture nouvelle qui sera une des
premières briques lancées qui permettra
d'amorcer des fonds qui viendront
justement soutenir et et permettre le
lancement de la de la cité des contacts
qui sont déjà établis avec de potentiels
artisans qui pourraient venir produire à
Jouin Josas on a énormément d'intérêt
aussi bien d'artisans qui sont heureux
de voir que d'abord ce type de dynamique
s'installe en région parisienne de voir
que effectivement il pourrai se
rassembler dans des spécialités qui leur
sont chères dans un lieu un peu plus
identifié et puis on est aussi très
soutenu par des entreprises des
fondations euh qui valorisent des
métiers d'art ou ou les savoir-faes
textiles parce que c'est vraiment il y a
des enjeux derrière très importants qui
vont dans le sens de de de la
réindustrialisation et de la de de de de
de de de la redécouverte de certains
savoir-faire en fait hein et aujourd'hui
toile de jou estce que c'est une marque
déposée je sais queil y a la volonté euh
que qu'on aille vers une sorte
d'appellation d'origine contrôlée si je
puis dire exactement ça c'est l'enjeu à
terme euh mais pour avoir une
appellation d'origine contrôlée il faut
que l'or
redevienne réelle et Jovacienne et en
attendant effectivement oui il y a une
marque toile de jou qui est en train
d'être d'être d'être officiellement
déposé alors le coût du projet on en a
parlé le lieu où sera situé cette toile
de jou vous avez commencé à en parler
tout à l'heure est-ce qu'il y a un
terrain qui est identifié un site
identifié retenu en plein cœur de ville
donc environ donc une parcelle d'un
hectare à l'emplacement historique même
de la manuf facture de burcanf donc pour
le symbole avec une très forte
connectivité puisque la gare est juste à
côté et le site est également à 800 m du
château du montsel qui était une des
demeures d'obercanf qui va devenir un
hôtel de luxe le domaine du moncell qui
va ouvrir en début d'année donc on
serait beaucoup plus central dans la
commune de Jouin Josas par rapport au
musée actuel de la toile jou qui est un
peu plus excentré c'est bien ça ça fait
partie des réflexions hein le musée il
avait besoin il arrive un petit peu au
bout de tout ce qu'il était capable
d'offrir et et son
emplacement sa taille faisait qu'il
fallait mener une réflexion donc ça ça
tombe au bon moment une dernière
question quel est le calendrier que vous
fixez pour ce projet alors le calendrier
on va dire qu'on a on a une cible pour
2030 mais l'idée c'est vraiment de
déployer le projet en brique par étape
euh en privilégiant notamment des
briques qui vont justement permettre
d'amorcer des des financements privés
complémentaires dont la manufacture
nouvelle qu'on a évoqué euh on a on a
également évoqué la partie redevance et
royalties puisqueaujourd'hui la marque
étant protégée il est plus facile de
négocier ça ça va être important voilà
juste voudrais profiter pour dire un
dernier mot euh un des facteurs clés de
succès de ce projet sera vraiment son
ancrage local et donc je tenais à dire
que le la la la la toile de joui est est
soutenue et aimée par les les citoyens
de la ville donc ça c'est quand même un
point qui est très important et d'autre
part donc un soutien important au niveau
de Versailles Grand Parc donc avec
François deasierre Le le président
également le département puisque nous
avons le la chance d'avoir notre maèire
Marie-Line Aubert qui est également
vice-président du département et donc il
y a un très fort soutien sur ce projet
et ensuite aussi rendre un hommage au
Mair successifs de jou en Josas au
conseillers municipaux successifs qui
ont permis la rampe de lancement
puisqu'on parlait très rapidement du
musée de la toile de jouis c'est une
véritable rampe de lancement pour la
cité et le musée est là il est bien
vivant aujourd'hui et donc vous pouvez
vous rendre au musée pour déjà euh aller
à la rencontre des des des collections
toiles de jou qui sont exposées et et
quelque part toucher déjà le projet de
vos doigts on a vu quelques-unes des
images au cours de cet entretien
notamment les nouvelles salles qui
avaient été inaugurées il y a de cela 1
an à joui en Josas merci en tout cas
d'être venu en plateau pour parler de ce
projet cité de la toile Christophe rueau
maire adjoint de Jouan Josas délégé à
l'attractivité au développement
économique merci également à vous
Charlotte Duvivier lebrin directrice du
Musée de la toile de jouille voilà c'est
la fin du 78 merci pour votre fidélité
demain nouvelle édition et vous
retrouverez Mathilde Francou très belle
soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78